Obama to the rescue that's the focus of
tonight's angle now why now why did
Barack Obama decide to come out to
publicly inject himself into the DOJ
Flynn saga there is no that anybody can
find for someone who's been charged with
perjury getting off scot-free that's the
kind of stuff where you you begin to get
worried that our basic understanding of
rule of law is it risk now in the end
well the FBI's entrapment of trumps and
a former national security adviser be
best known as Obama gate well I'll tell
you many questions tonight need
answering why did Obama know about
Flynn's call with kiss lyac before the
acting Attorney General even knew about
it why didn't he tell the incoming
president about those specific concerns
why did Susan Rice write that memo to
the file we noted it at the time this
weird memo written at noon on
inauguration day the last possible
second saying that President Obama
wanted everything done via V Flynn by
the book we're gonna address these
questions in depth in a few moments now
sure Obama wanted to get out in front of
the obvious conclusions that he was
green-lighting all of this anti Trump
effort from day one but I also suspect
another motivation is at play as well
one word legacy does he want to be
remembered for hope and change or
surveillance and setups for the past
three years after his party stinging
loss in 2016
Barack Obama avoided pretty much
tangling with the Trump administration
the only time in fact he seemed like the
old Obama was in 2018 when he hit the
campaign trail even for losing
candidates
[Applause]
there are a lot of good reasons to come
to Miami I've got the ocean you've got
really good Cuban sandwiches but the
real reason I came down to Miami because
this Tuesday might be the most important
election of our lifetimes politicians
will always say that but this time it's
actually true of course with all the
same swagger he's gonna pair it that
line again when he's on the campaign
trail for Joe Biden because it's not
just the presidency on the line it's
Obama's entire legacy when a brash
political novice like Trump beat the
Democrats in 2016 it wasn't just a
repudiation of Hillary Clinton it also
was a rejection of what Obama had
accomplished as well now in case you've
forgotten after eight years of Obama
race relations weren't better they were
worse after eight years of Obama the
right track wrong track numbers were
also bad wages were also flat the
trans-pacific partnership was so lame
that Obama supported even Hillary
Clinton wouldn't run on it the Paris
climate Accords they were never ratified
so the Obama progressive utopia
collapsed
no wonder Trump won for the history
books he needs to turn that perception
around he needs to show the American
people that they made a mistake in Trump
which may have compelled them of course
them being the FBI etc to entrap Flynn
in January we're gonna find out soon I
hope all those details now due to the
global pandemic President Obama now sees
the November election as winnable he
doesn't want to be left being criticized
as letting this one slip through the
Democrats fingers but of course there's
one little problem here Obama isn't on
the ticket and I don't think he's gonna
leave that high life at Netflix become
Joe's Secretary of State do you
this this all reminds me of it's kind of
like Hollywood trying to sell a movie
sequel but the lead actor from the
original only ends up making a brief
cameo in the new one
in this case Obama at the biden
inauguration the democrats and their
media poodles will flail away at
president Trump for a pandemic that
China started we've seen that but
meanwhile their presumptive nominee is
actually incapable of standing up and
taking questions from pretty much anyone
even comedians but doing a lot of you
know a lot of live stream things that
are getting just getting used to and and
it's but it amazes me that everybody is
you know tuned it in so many different
ways to find out what's going on well
they have a candidate who can't campaign
and the likely VP candidate I don't
think that's going to help them much
either one okay I love the forced
laughter so how do you win an election
when your ticket if it ends up being the
ticket even is not it's so lame so are
people to believe that Biden watching
everything that's happening just over
the past few months that Biden would
better handle the pandemic then Trump
please he can't even handle an interview
with the view the house and the senator
the Senate as of ten minutes before I
got in this call I mean this excuse me
this call this from the program looks
like they're pretty close to a deal
widow sorry I did I can't believe that
someone running for president would
Biden have worked better with our allies
I don't know to stand up to China for
its lying about the virus maybe they'll
argue that well that's absurd
it's face china is going to eat our
lunch come on man you know they're not
bad folks folks but guess what they're
not a competition for us which brings us
back to why obama has emerged from his
important work at netflix to inject
himself back into politics he's a smart
guy he obviously sees the point that I
just laid out
he knows Biden is shaky and that he
can't possibly match the grassroots
energy of Trump on the trail Obama knows
it thus a Back to the Future strategy
for Democrats may be their best bet
ultimately though this shows just think
about it for a moment
it shows a complete intellectual
bankruptcy on their part they can't
point to a single example as to why
their policies would do better than
Trump's either before or after the
coronavirus hit our shores and they
can't really put Biden out there for an
extended period of time without America
seeing his obvious frailty for most
candidates being locked in the basement
that would be a bad thing but for Biden
it's a gift
that leaves the Obama to do the heavy
lifting
who needs Biden obviously to win for his
own legacy as much as his party's future
and that's the angle